Get ready for a tragicomic clash of the symbiotes.
Venom star Tom Hardy recently took to Instagram
to post cool fan art based on the classic
tragedy and comedy masks that date back to
Greek theater.
These have a lot more tongue, though.
Hardy clearly relishes playing the iconic
Marvel antihero, and the artwork makes reference
to Venom's post-credits scene, which indicated
that Venom will have his hands full in his
second outing on the big screen.
In the scene, Hardy's Eddie Brock, an investigative
reporter, visits serial killer Cletus Kasady,
played by Woody Harrelson, to write a story
about him.
After a brief and creepy round of niceties,
Kasady makes a statement that's equal parts
threat and promise.
"When I get out of here, and I will, there's
gonna be carnage."
Brock may be a bit morally conflicted, but
Kasady created by writer David Michelinie
and artist Erik Larsen answered the unnerving
question of what would happen if a symbiote
were to take control of a truly evil person:
Carnage, a being so unbelievably malevolent
and dangerous that in the comics, Spidey and
Venom have been forced to team up on multiple
occasions to stop him.
Harrelson's return to take on the villainous
mantle in Venom 2 was confirmed earlier this
year, and it's plain that Hardy is clearly
pumped for fans to witness the epic throwdown.
Hardy captioned the image with a coded message
which, interestingly, could be read as "We
are Venom 2" as in the numeral two, or the
word "too," meaning "also."
In the comics, Kasady's symbiote was a spawn
of Venom, so there could be some interesting
subtext there.
There's been widespread speculation that Venom
2 will carry an R rating, but producer Avi
Arad told Collider in 2018,
"When you hear Carnage, the only thing you
can think of is R. But, if you know his story,
if you really know the comic, there's no R
there.
He's a tortured soul.
It's not about what he does [...] What you
have to show is, what is the motivation?
Was he born like that, or [is he] someone
we should feel for?
Because if you succeeding in making a villain
someone you can feel for, jackpot."
If Venom 2 indeed carries the same PG-13 rating
as its predecessor, this opens the door to
another question, especially in light of the
recent breakup and reconciliation between
Sony Pictures and Marvel Studios:
“Where's your pal, Spider-Man?
Let me guess, in Canada with your imaginary
girlfriend?"
There has been endless speculation about whether
Hardy's Venom and Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
who has appeared in three Marvel Studios films
and two Sony-produced, MCU-set solo vehicles,
will ever meet onscreen.
Both actors seem quite psyched about the prospect,
and a number of involved parties have teased
that it's not only possible, but inevitable.
Before the Sony/Disney kerfuffle, no less
an authority than Marvel Studios head honcho
Kevin Feige said that a crossover, quote,
"seems likely at some point," while making
it clear that in his mind, that ball was firmly
in Sony's court.
After the release of the mega-hit Spider-Man:
Far From Home, director Jon Watts told ComicBookMovie.com
that, creatively speaking, he saw no reason
why the comic book nemeses couldn't meet up
on the big screen at some point.
He said:
"I found Venom to be so funny and I thought
Tom Hardy was so great, I don't know that
[the two universes] are so different.
I think you put those two Toms together and
you're going to see something pretty special."
While the two stars have in the past expressed
a general interest in working together, neither
have had anything to say about whether a Spidey/Venom
collision is officially in the works.
For Hardy's part, though, he couldn't help
but throw a bit of gasoline on that flame
with a photo of himself dressed, well, rather
provocatively, which he posted to and then
deleted from his Instagram account last month.
Either Hardy knows something we don't, or
he simply enjoys screwing with fans from time
to time.
For the time being, we're going to have to
go with the latter; Holland's Spider-Man has
been confirmed to be appear in one more Sony-produced
solo flick and an additional Marvel Studios
film at this time, and it's been reported
that Venom 2 begins shooting this month with
director Andy Serkis at the helm.
Whether Spidey makes an appearance or not,
though, we're pumped to see Hardy's anti-hero
face off with one of the deadliest foes in
Marvel comics.
Sony has not yet announced a release date
for Venom 2, but the flick is expected to
drop in fall 2020, so we'll keep our ears
to the ground for details, and keep you informed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about upcoming
movie sequels are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.